dune was a visual spectacle that was
like an art director's wet dream and the
whole time i'm watching this movie i'm
like jesus oscar isaac's beard looks
amazing
what's up gq i'm maddie conrad i am a
men's grooming expert today we're gonna
dissect some of the world's finest
celebrity beards
now let's face it not everybody looks
better with a beard i have guys ask me
every single day if they should grow a
beard or not let's look at some of these
celebrities and decide whether or not a
beard is the best look for them now
these are just my opinion as
somewhat of a beard grooming expert
jason mamoa
jason momoa has a slightly straighter
more kind of wavy beard a lot of guys
when they grow those wavy beards out
have kind of a pirate vibe to them
because they have a little bit more kind
of shimmy they're a little bit more
pissy and scraggly but what i love about
jason momoa's beard is that it
completely suits the rest of his look
because he really does kind of look like
a pirate i don't think i could picture
jason momoa with a really well tuned up
and outlined beard i think this whole
thing suits his aesthetic very very well
he rides motorbikes he likes to get
dirty he likes to do activities and
climbing stuff he's a very physical guy
but a lot of these kinds of longer
straighter beards are going to have a
more triangular shape just by their
nature it's really hard to get
straighter hair to look more square so
it's a really nice way to use the
texture of his hair to grow into a shape
that's complementary to his face i can't
even picture jason momoa without a beard
now it's such a part of his identity and
i think that he definitely definitely
looks better with a beard i mean this is
one of those times where both are very
handsome but one of them looks like
jason momoa
oscar isaac
i mean oscar isaac is somebody that
could go either way he looks great
without a beard he looks great with a
beard but if i had to pick my preference
and my favorite i'm gonna go with the
beard i am bias i'm such a fan of his
beard it was my favorite part of that
movie here's the thing about oscar
isaac's beard he keeps it in a very
consistent shape he understands what
shape is going to suit his face best he
has got a much more squared out shape
because his face shape is slightly more
of what we would consider kind of
inverted triangle so it's a little
narrower at the bottom and a little
wider at the top so having that long
strong square beard at the bottom really
helps balance out his shape gives him a
very square overall appearance which we
kind of interpret as very handsome i
also really appreciate how he's embraced
the way it turns a little bit salt and
peppery and a little bit gray a lot of
guys will color their beard when the
gray starts coming in because they're a
little worried that it ages them but
before you know it it looks like their
beard has been drawn on by a magic
marker in 2019 you can see his beard's
really quite dark he's starting to get a
little bit of salt and pepper into the
sides but it's a flawless shape for his
face a little bit leaner into like 2020
you know when he wants to dress up when
he wants to go to a nice event which is
still a very good shape for him but i
think in contrast to how he looked for
dune in 2021
hands down this is one of my favorite
looks as far as a full beard goes and
that nice consistent salt and pepper
look can look really really sharp in a
beard without having to go through all
the coloring
[Music]
nick offerman
this is a guy that redefined facial hair
for men in this last decade nick
offerman is a great example of how
important the relationship between beard
shape and face shape is growing a beard
out is not just necessarily about
letting everything grow in all
directions it does require some sorts of
shaping the real reason we have beards
in the first place is to complement and
strengthen the look of the jaw you have
maybe what he was wearing in about 2018
i'm pretty sure he did this for a roll
everything is just grown out in all
directions it's not very lean on the
sides it doesn't have a lot of strong
jaw-like shape to it so it's not in my
opinion the most flattering thing for
him
but when he starts to change the shape
of that up especially into maybe 2019 or
even into 2020 when he took the sides a
lot leaner he's got a stronger baseline
and all the length is sitting at the
chain it gives him a really strong
masculine representation he looks like a
very strong jaw and to me this is more
nick offerman's vibe because at the very
core i think that a beard has to match
your personality just as much as it
matches your face shape or your texture
you know i really like nick offerman
with a beard i've seen him without a
beard it looks a little more youthful
and looks a little bit softer but
there's something about a beard that
really enhances the look of nick
offerman's face to me
he is the beard
james harden
now when it comes to beards it's not
just about the hollywood elite sometimes
we're looking at sports celebrities and
you can't talk about sports and beards
without mentioning the name james harden
james harden was drafted in 2009 and he
was relatively clean-shaven at the time
in 2010 he started growing a beard and
as far as i can tell he never looked
back he is absolutely committed to this
look and i think it really suits him on
a lot of other guys that i see with
beards in the nba they keep them a
little more tailored and a little more
well groomed but harden seems to let his
grow really wild and wooly and i kind of
love that because it i think really
intimidates the other players it's a big
beard to have coming at you and i've
seen this done in other sports like
rugby and like soccer where guys will
grow these big beards in an attempt to
be more imposing in an attempt to be
more confident looking and more
aggressive looking really important that
when you are wearing a beard that has
that kind of density and you let things
get a little wild that you balance that
out somehow with something that is
groomed in his case it's his like
meticulous braids it's his perfect
lineups he always has a really nice
clean fade so it's a great way to kind
of create a juxtaposition between the
two that overall when you combine them
still creates a style not just a lack of
style james harden gets a thumbs up for
this beard for me
[Music]
lebron james
keeping it on the court let's look at
lebron james now lebron james has a very
different beard shape from james harden
it is a much more low rise and the
difference is that his top line is much
much lower it's carved really down tight
and instead of that wild and wooly look
he keeps his very very flawlessly
groomed nice down low very strong lines
which looks great from the profile looks
amazing from the side but as soon as
he's looking directly at you you can see
that it really kind of amplifies the
narrowness of his jaw and that's a thing
that you can see without a beard here he
has a very narrow bottom jaw lebron is a
really tough one because i actually like
him better with a beard but not this
beard instead of complimenting the shape
of his face it's amplifying the shape of
his face and that is a little bit tricky
because if we compare that to somebody
that's maybe not on the court maybe
somebody that's sitting courtside like
drake
[Music]
he has almost the exact same beard shape
as lebron james but his face shape is
different and it complements the shape
better drake is a little wider his chin
is not quite so narrow and so when he
creates that same low rider shape that's
meticulously groomed out you can see it
complements his face shape and in fact
gives it a more square look if you want
to put these two side by side who wore
it better
i think drake's got you lebron
[Music]
chris pine
chris pine is definitely your classic
handsome hollywood leading man in 2022
chris pine really put this look together
he grew his hair out longer he's got
this big beard it's got a lot of gray in
it and i think it really aged him it
really gave him a much much older look
and i think it's really tricky to grow
out a beard and your hair at the same
time if you're trying to make it a style
statement now perfect contrast here is
when we see what happens when you pull
his hair back off his face he pushes it
back it looks leaner on the sides i know
it's wearing a hoodie but just the shape
looks so much better one of the things i
usually recommend to guys is that if
they want to grow their beard out bigger
then they should make their haircut
cleaner and maybe a little shorter or
more groomed i love that he embraces how
strong his gray is in the front he's got
that real tonal difference which can be
very interesting and can make your beard
stand out if you ask me this is not
chris pine's best look i mean for a roll
i get it for the coloration that he's
got he's got a very interesting looking
beard but i really believe that when you
try and grow everything out all at once
you start to lose a lot you lose your
jaw shape you lose your overall square
shape and things become kind of rounder
without a beard that is really handsome
already leave some for the rest of us
why don't you
donald glover
donald glover is a great example of
bringing out that mature aspect that a
beard can give you i think a lot of
people got to know him about 10 years
ago when he was on community and he
played this real boyish charm he had a
bit of a baby face but as he got away
from that role and as he went into his
childish gambino phase i think he wanted
to express more of his maturity and his
sexuality and i really think that the
beard helped him do that i think there
was an evolution to donald glover's
beard i know he played around with a
couple different shapes it started out
with kind of a rounder shape
which is not always the most flattering
on certain types of face shapes
especially because he has a slightly
rounder face shape but i think he's
settled on more of a squared out shape
now and that squared out shape is really
what's giving that amplitude to his jaw
and that stronger look so in the spirit
of donald glover expressing his maturity
i think that a beard is a much better
look for him than without
idris elba
he's such a man isn't he he's so
masculine and he's got such a strong
personality and so when he has this
beard and he keeps it nice and short and
tight and embraces his salt and pepper i
think it's a great look for him instead
of making it really edged out and look
drawn on he keeps it a little bit more
natural but still very nice and tight
this is really easy to maintain yourself
at home with a pair of clippers but what
works about it for idris elba is it's
something that he can always dress up or
dress down and it looks great both ways
i mean idris elba is such an interesting
character already because he's not just
a hollywood leading man a guy's a dj i
mean he has so many elements to his
personality and i think the really great
thing about this is that beard just
seems to be consistent through all of
those elements so idris elba's beard for
me is a great big win especially for
guys that are looking to have something
that they can maintain themselves at
home but still give them just that tiny
bit of masculine edge
[Applause]
jon hamm
when it comes to some actors they're
known for having a beard jon hamm for me
is not one of those actors when i
picture jon hamm it's really impossible
for me to not see his clean shaven don
draper kind of vibe he's such a handsome
guy without facial hair and so when you
see him with facial hair it's almost
like he's wearing a costume or he's
hiding or something and it almost looks
like the beard stands out quite a bit i
mean he can definitely grow in he can
definitely wear it it's not a bad thing
on his face shape for me it just doesn't
seem to be his style by contrast you
take an actor like jake gyllenhaal
for some reason it just seems to work
with him a little better it seems to be
a little more seamless and it kind of
integrates into his style a little bit
better i've seen him without one and he
looks great i've seen him with a beard
he looks fantastic and it's not quite as
much of a disconnect for me to look at
jake gyllenhaal's beard and say that
suits you as it is to look at john
hamsburg and say that's your best look
jake gyllenhaal is another one of those
ones where it's too close to call
because he looks great without one he
looks great with one but i love the kind
of more mature look he has with the
beard so i'm gonna say with a beard
[Music]
reggie watts
reggie watts has a very iconic look all
his own he's a comedian and a performer
who really uses his look as part of his
physical comedy he embraces the the
craziness of his hair that large texture
of it he wears in all sorts of really
bright and bold ways which i think is
super fun but to do that really requires
you to be able to anchor something at
the bottom of your face shape otherwise
it just starts to look very top heavy
and so he uses his beard to kind of
anchor that shape to feel a little more
natural a little rougher and again very
consistent with the rest of his look
this guy is absolutely hilarious and i
can't picture him without a beard i mean
let's take a picture of reggie before he
had his beard and let's just see what
the beard shape has done for his face
shape
i mean undeniable
keanu reeves
[Music]
keanu reeves is like
the like the hollywood version of jesus
you know what i mean you can't say bad
things about keanu reeves it's not my
favorite beard i i think keanu reeves
looks best when he has something that is
really tight and tailored he looks great
clean-shaven he looks great with like a
little bit of stubble you know when he's
got that kind of john wick vibe going or
a very very short beard because his face
shape is so narrow and because he's
really lean looking the longer the beard
grows with the longer hair it starts to
kind of elongate the shape too much so
for keanu reeves i love to see his beard
shorter and more kind of tailored in
it's just more complementary to his face
shape i'm gonna say without a beard
i know that's a little controversial i
just really like his face shape without
a beard i think if he was gonna wear one
keep it really short almost stubbly so
yeah i'm going to stay without
well guys that's all i've got for now
but if you want to see some more comment
and subscribe below if there's beards in
hollywood that you think deserves some
more attention than they've got add them
to the comment section and until then
we'll see you next time